. Let's go to the phone lines at (617) 830-4750.
I know a lot of questions on people's minds
about much of what is going on politically.
Let's start with our color from the eight
six zero area code color from eight, six zero.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Oh, Hey David, this is Matt.
I'm calling from Granby, Connecticut.
Hey Matt.
What's up?
Oh, I was just, I just wanted to know like
what your opinion was on guns and stuff like
that and where you kind of stand on the second
amendment.
Uh, well the second amendment exists and I
don't think that, um, that is going to change
anytime soon.
So I think that our gun safety activism needs
to account for that and, and basically all
of it does.
So I'm in favor of, um, expanded checks.
I'm in favor of a national gun registry.
I'm in favor of, um, having systems to ensure
that people who are potentially a danger to
themselves or others can even relatively quickly
temporarily be restricted from having firearms.
I believe in requiring insurance if you are
going to have a gun, much like people who,
if you have a car in most States, you're required
to have car insurance.
Uh, my, I'm in favor of that as well with
firearms.
Uh, I'm in favor of making ammunition pretty
damn expensive.
Uh, I mean, I don't know.
These are some of my ideas.
Cool.
And um, well this is more of a followup where,
where D what's your stance on concealable
handguns?
Do you think they should be outlawed?
Cause I was having a debate with someone and
I was saying I think we should have handguns,
but I think all hand guns should be pretty
hard to conceal, you know, like a like full
size hand guns and stuff like that.
You know, I actually have a strong position
on that.
I know that there are lots of different arguments
about why concealed carry versus open carry
is, is better, worse or, or the same in terms
of safety for one safety for others.
I actually don't, I don't know enough about
it to be able to say for sure.
For sure.
Yeah, I got you.
Okay.
I really appreciate that David.
Thanks for having the question.
All right.
Matt from Connecticut, thank you so much for
the phone call.
I appreciate it.